walk into this video I'm playing Hagen
again the spanish guy he has always
playing 1b3 yeah really b3 all the time
all that time it's got 55,000 games in
the five-minute pool and probably half
of them what be three okay so I'm trying
for a solid set up here so maybe I can
lay he's not doing much she right maybe
i can i can play em play it somewhat
conservatively here first and then then
do something active like g5 here I've
the fianchetto is quite often not a bad
setup really against this kind of this
kind of structure mmm but okay I can
still make some some more improvement
moves it's not like that he has has much
oke form okay I'm going back to c5
that's not a bad square
I like this position how do i play now I
would like to play a 5 at some point and
night to e6 also would also be very
helpful okay rukon c8 and Bishop on b7
they make a weird impression now maybe
he's right h4 is what I was concerned
about I can I can play g6 though it's
not it's not terrible or queen e cigs
much not a big problem okay he's
probably trying to regroup on the night
of my ac3 but I I don't mind dad maybe I
can even do this and place the 65 yeah I
like that this isn't this is active now
I have all my pieces in the middle and
even d5 I can play here right d 55 maybe
it's not doing that much I come on let's
prepare this with c6
okay let's let's take him and what now
if I've always have 95 that's not very
very scary so probably go here maybe
2017 age 3 as a move activating the
Queen to getting home getting asking I'm
sorry for what he did though he played
quickly tweenage three is now hmm
something to pay attention okay let's go
let's go down your Bishop g4 coming
maybe
I would like to and I cannot do
something tactical here unfortunately
with this bishop on c5c 5g 194 we can
really kick in just with the pawn and it
didn't really do much good
how to do that maybe h 5h for penny
sorry about my voice I think I need you
to drink something but first finish the
game yeah that's not really great that I
had to allow this yeah not great
now this is better for right now before
was good yeah I probably should have
tried to yeah hard to prevent but do
something against it at least that it's
not coming with full effect this is this
is now really a bit uncomfortable I
wanted to have Bishop t44 okay I need to
I need this age point push the only
counterplay his bishop on see oneness is
not not great as well which is some
something to hope for like yo que a
bishop my queen has no square Sam Wow
time morning
hmm playing for 95 95 with something
though he needs to he needs to do
something about it now I can he can be i
er do that rook f7 know about wow this
is strong this is strong really okay
check check sure there are not much to
do yeah normally I fair pretty pretty
decently against the sky but not this
time 12 out of 14 is my school so it's a
gel to score a rare win I really think
at try to edit ok position that at one
point but check check it's not not the
slightest hope here black resigns yeah
this rook a6 business I mean it's just
really that bad for me i really i don't
know maybe I'm just playing something
yeah yeah this is very good Jim that's
very good forward the whole before
business was really a throwing a spanner
in the works this is this was a problem
we should be six still seems to be ok
but yeah very very difficult very
difficult type of position
maybe I shouldn't really take this could
be a mistake really activating a snide
now yeah that's that's a positional
mistake I should I should just keep the
position as it is keeping a pawn on d5
so that you cannot take that you cannot
go to see forming yeah this is this is
fairly okay so this was the position a
mistake that I committed allowing his
Knight to c4 okay cheering okay well it
isn't clear but it is a position where I
I need to be super precise and it's hard
hard to do and Ti assistance is now very
very strong I need you now do something
cg six is losing but I hadn't really I
only looked mostly a drug a seven and
not a truck a six and this is really the
the problem okay successor the thing
that kills me okay thanks for watching